we are finally free a movie depicting
the 1986 people's uprising that toppled
the government of ferdinand marcus
inside the presidential palace from the
perspective of demarcus
the film is showing just months after
the election of the former leader's son
president ferdinand marcus jr it is
being promoted as a true story
but historians say clips that have been
circulating online have not been
consistent with the established truth
this scene shows then opposition leader
corazon aquino who later restored
democracy as president nonchalantly
playing majon while the revolution was
raging
crossing the line is really it's really
hard to say
but the intention
is very clear to me already
especially with the scene with the
covason aquino
just saying you know very very
carelessly get them out of the
philippines and then goes to the
major table with nuns
the elder marcos ruled for 21 years
amassed an estimated 5 to 10 billion
dollars worth of unexplained wealth
and was responsible for tens of
thousands of wrongful imprisonments
torture and killings according to human
rights advocates
none of this was in the movie
another film about his administration
however opened on the same day
is about student activism and how the
marcus government then responded with
brutality
our purpose here is not only to
entertain more important than that we
are here to educate people and the
history is something which is forgotten
already it was distorted and revised so
we really need to
remind our young people about the
importance of history
which was a musical before it went on
the big screen has been earning rave
reviews and reaping awards
and hailed as being more accurate in its
depiction of the senior marcus's iron
fist rule critics of ferdinand marcus jr
say his victory in the election was a
victory for disinformation
now that this information has come to
the movie theaters of the philippines
those critics will be hoping truth will
prevail this time
barnaba al jazeera manila